bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono già non c'è già
più fiato
io sono fuori j oggi siamo tornati su
cleverbot ragazzi perché me l'avete
chiesto praticamente tutti di
continuarlo dopo il primo episodio che è
piaciuto tantissimo ragazzi veramente
grazie è stato tutto merito della sua
intelligenza ok forse no ragazzi vediamo
iniziare come si deve perché stavolta
voglio fare una conversazione seria
allora vediamo che cosa posso partire
per una cosa semplice come sta io sono
qua vj piacere semplice ciao come sai io
sono fabbri non fa bridge è l'hotel e vi
rispondo mia mente in inglese nel caso
non te ne fossi accorto io sono italiano
precisiamo le sue cose perché non si sa
mai che dove il cazzo si va a finire nel
caso al telefono ok go gna dobbiamo
riuscire agazzi non è possibile di gago
madonna ma che cazzo dici
lady gaga madonna muoio ai ragazzi un
cazzo di sé morion non hai opere ferme
da allora io sono cazzo italiano ok note
mi può essere interpretata malissimo st
comma non importa io no io sono cazzo
italiano ok io sono italiano e francese
volevo vincere ma se me la prende voglio
l'oscar e basta perché mi chiedo per
questo alle due deve parisi va beh
perché io non sono un compratore ha
vissuto parlato giamaicano mi parli
italiano mi sembra giusto piacere sono
favi jackie a celle sono fabio dj ma
vaffan
mi sento male cosa ti senti io non so
chi ha fame di autolesionismo
ma chiacchia ci sono passato anch'io
quando giocava hacket mario quindi ti
capisco ragazzi che come approcciare i
discorsi come cristo comanda e
fantastico lo so ci sono passato anch'io
quando giocava al cat mario quindi dica
come casa ma prenderò una frase del
genere imporsi diamo
asca perfetto parliamone prima per la
scheda che cosa ti attrae di me voglio
capire che cazzo che il conte riesco a
parlare perfetto allora ti va di uscire
ragazzi l'ultima volta ci ho messo dei
secoli per chiederle stavolta subito non
ti sempre a troppo presto per dirmelo
perché a terra sembra come presto per
limitiamo nicchia come tokyo usa non mi
sembra troppo presto usciamo stasera
stasera vai così cosa buffa melo in
forza ragazzi diverto con un deficiente
segreti cosa mio culetto ti piace se ti
sculazzo il culetto di la verità ragazzi
sta cosa sta diventando la è peggio
dell'altra volta cioè non ho mai avuto
come sa di certo a pec
a me piace sculaccia micah p
la risposta non mi piace sculaccia mib
ed è un controsenso baby baby baby
continuato la canzone
baby baby baby doll eyes baby cazzo ma
no
[Musica]
addio
ma pagando ragazzi si come nello scorso
nello scorso episodio dove ho chiesto
nei commenti che se mi scrive rate delle
domande da fare a cleverbot voglio
scegliere quelle più carine così almeno
vediamo di chiedergli qualcosa di strano
e bellezza ti langue di share solo io e
te questa mi piace e bellezza
ti va un po di schweppes sono io e te
oppure di come mi interpreti schweppes
questa è la cosa più negativa di tutto
bellezza di voi un pò di chance mi ha
preso suazo
ti piace fa vj chi sa ma io ci provo
ragazzo ti piace fa vj non ce la farà
mai lo scrivono correttamente c'è
sticazzi la categoria no guardi video di
youtube e se sì ti piacciono a noi e lo
scrivo così perché non è possibile se
non ce la farò mai
abbiate pazienza vai così spero mi
sappia rispondere recentemente perfetto
guarda i miei video
adesso continuo e aspetta un attimo e
quale vi do ti piace di più ti risponde
quello che penso quante mazzate quando
fa la voce una donna aprì la porta sono
nuto vabbè prova a fare questa ma non
per ora vediamo di riuscire a farmi
invitare prima di prima le chiedo se ex
gli piaccio l'aspetta ti piaccio spero
spero in una risposta se beppe è la
partenza è buona il bar di uscire con me
ragazzi certo grande mica che si
avvicina il solito ultima volta è
affatto impossibile ci siamo ragazzi
aspettate che non ci posso credere
allora mi inviti a casa casa tua
vieni grandissimo non ci posso credere
che ci sono riuscito subito ma è così ho
paura di cosa scrive ho veramente paura
di che cazzo mi scrive ora bacio cioè
che cazzo è un orgasmo con un bacio
spiega bacio allora faccio anch'io
andiamo avanti così è un bacio con la
lingua
i caffè è l'ingaggio con le chiappe
non lo so dato che non so che scambio di
sali ma che schifo ragazzi sta
diventando vietato 18 sto coso cioè
censurate tutto sputo nell'occhio dato
che stiamo parlando di cose romantiche
ci siamo
ti bacio belliche funzionati palco
i ragazzi e fanta di cocco
mi piace cazzo succede che cazzo sta
succedendo reja fermi è una cosa sta
diventando trasgressivo e la calma ma
voglio soltanto vedere dove cazzo vuole
arrivare perché non ha senso è una casa
ma chi cazzo si riveste poi ci stanca
per è stato è stato malinteso è stato un
completo chi svestono a siri riveste tra
gli altri cioè cazzo succede calmi è una
claudio mi rivesto meletole bravissimo
grande è nato prima l'uovo o la gallina
[Musica]
il gallina perfetto ma cosa me l'avete
c'è stato mi avete detto richiede non ci
provo
non volevo pensare la risposta visto che
non promette già bene di suo ci sta
pensando però stavolta non me l'hanno
già fatta questa domanda
lo sapete che cosa hai risposto nel caso
di sma più esatto padre si fuma una
canna era sigaretta elettronica comunque
amato non troppo farglielo fare lì ti ha
creato questa ragazzi e splendida come
domanda come avete chiesto di fare mia
mamma e mio papà ma se sei un robot
ragazzi voglio provare a chiedergli un
seriamente perché anche i robot andò
istinti sessuali allora dov'è il tuo
culo ragazzi lorenzo 26 mio nome come
cazzo lo sanno non mica devo
preoccuparmi sei una stalker degli
assist a cosa si mette anche lei per
forza misti ragazzi sta cosa sta sempre
ambarabaciccicoccò non so chi a cazzotti
ma barzagli sono lo scritto ma li sento
sempre expelliarmus ragazzi che stiamo
andando sui cantelli mitra uno scontro
epico ragazzi a palla che va a bra
[ __ ] never be light conflitto con
questo ho vinto ma ragazzi ha concluso
più perché di domande serie e
intelligenti soprattutto le ho finite
fatemi sapere se sapete qualcosa la
chiede non so qualsiasi che ho visto che
conosce tutto scrivetemi la domanda da
fare nel prossimo episodio ragazzi
perché di sicuro lo faccio perché
spettacolare lega mi diverto troppo e
quindi io direi che posso concludere qui
il club sa i ragazzi servito è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace kawasaki
che cazzo scrive vabbè è la lasciamo
perdere non fa niente se sei video è
piaciuto ragazzi lasciato un commento mi
piace anche a valiani facebook come non
i video tratte nella descrizione stasera
prestiti iscrivetevi ci rivediamo il
prossimo vi do belle ragazze